hi my name is silva cuberta and today i
will be talking about faster sparse
matrix inversion and run computation in
finite fields this is john work with
rasmus king
so before i focus on the problem of
matrix inversion let me begin by giving
an overview of the complexity of the
main linear algebra algorithms and how
they relate to one another
so let's start with the problem of
solving a linear system which is
arguably the most fundamental problem in
linear algebra
so if we want to solve a x equals b we
have many different methods which we can
broadly classify into the main two
branches
one is the so-called direct methods
which consist of first finding a inverse
or an implicit representation of it and
then applying the vector b to 2a inverse
this would include for example a
gaussian elimination celestial
factorization or qr decomposition
on the other hand we have the so-called
alternative methods which successively
refine the solution vector x
this is done for example by conjugate
gradient or by the language algorithm
so we already see that there's a very
clear relationship between the problem
of matrix inversion and the problem of
linear system solving namely if we
directly compute a inverse then we
automatically have a solver for linear
equations in a
now if we relate these problems to that
of matrix multiplication which is a
runtime that we care about in instances
then strassen already showed in the 60s
that you can reduce matrix inversion to
matrix multiplication
together this implies that we can solve
ax equals b in the real-world model in
time of n omega where omega denotes the
exponent of matrix multiplication that
is
o of n omega is a runtime required to
multiply two n by n matrices
naively omega has a value of 3 but this
value has been improved throughout the
years and currently has a best bound of
2.3728 youtube virginia vasiliska
williams and josh alma
but matrix inversion is also interesting
in its own right and it also allows us
to for example complete the rank of
matrix
lastly another very important factor
when talking about the complexity of
these linear algebra algorithms is the
sparsity of the input matrix
so if we consider the runtime of
performing one matrix vector product one
mvp
then if the matrix a is arbitrary this
takes of n squared
but if the matrix a is a sparse by which
we usually mean that it has o of n
non-zeros up to log factors then this
product takes only o of n instead of o
of n squared
however these runtimes in the real realm
can be very misleading
it was already shown by wilkinson that
gaussian elimination is not stable in
finite position arithmetic by default
and neither is conjugate gradient which
a priori has a runtime of n times n and
z of a where n and z denotes the number
of zeros of a but that's only in the
real round model
otherwise when we take bit sizes into
account this encourages a whole other
factor of n
so now we can do two things we either
start analyzing these algorithms from a
numerical analysis point of review and
see if we can control how the bit size
grows throughout the algorithm or we
switch and work in finite fields in
which there is no instability so
a finite field such as z model of p
so finite fields constitute a simpler
setting for developing fascinating
algebra algorithms
how do these two settings relate so we
have some adaptations of algorithms in
the reals um that were adapted to the
final kilo settings such as conjugate
gradient and the language algorithm
but there were also algorithms that were
directly developed for finite fields and
a very famous example is whitman's
algorithm which can solve a sparse
linear system over a finite field in n
times n and z of a field operations
so now we can build the following table
with the two problems that we have
discussed linear system solving and
matrix inversion in their sparse version
and compare the runtime in the finite
field setting and in the finite position
arithmetic setting
so this corresponds to widowman's
algorithm
this corresponds to the reduction i have
mentioned from matrix inversion to
matrix multiplication
now if you look at this cell it was a a
very important open question up until
last year to determine whether or not we
can solve sparsely or systems faster
than matrix multiplication
it was answered on the positive by
richard peng and santos van palla who
showed that unconditionally on the value
of omega yes we can solve sparse linear
systems faster than matrix
multiplication
this run time was very recently improved
some months ago to end to the 2.28 by z
payment
which matched
the runtime for sparse matrix inversion
over finite fields by everly at
and you can see from this table that the
most interesting open question is that
we do not yet know how to do sparse
matrix inversion over fine over finite
position arithmetic in less than matrix
multiplication time unlike uh linear
system solving so in this talk in our
paper we will focus on this cell which
is the runtime that we improved so the
runtime for sparse matrix inversion over
finite fields
[Music]
before i explain the construction for
our
algorithm for matrix inversion one more
remark on this interplay between um the
reals and finite fields so as i
mentioned there were some adaptations of
the finite position arithmetic
algorithms such as conjugate gradient
erlang those two finite fields
but the paper from peng and impala from
last year is very interesting because
they took uh the everly adult
construction which worked entirely on
finite fields and they showed how to
make it numerically stable
so that shows that um not only do finite
field setting algorithms provide a
simpler ground for developing algorithms
but potentially they can also be adapted
into the real setting
and lastly another very interesting way
of bridging this this gap is by using
dixon's rational reconstruction
algorithm so dickson
showed how to use periodic numbers to
construct the solution to a linear
system with a periodic expression and
then
show how we can
convert this very expression to an exact
rational solution
okay so now i will focus on matrix
inversion and describe the construction
of our algorithm
uh one remark is that in this talk i
will only talk about matrix inversion
but the same runtime can be
obtained to get the rank and true
complement and null space of the matrix
with the same
final run time
so we obtain a final expected run time
of this expression which hopefully by
the end of the talk we have explained
each term but for now the important
thing is that this corresponds to o of n
to the 221 31 when the input matrix is
sparse
we'll also see how our construction
implies general results about the
runtime for the explicit inversion of
structure matrices
and the two key technical components
behind our algorithm are displacement
operators and fast rectangular matrix
multiplication
so let me now describe the notation that
we will need in a visual manner
so phi of n denotes a runtime for one
matrix vector product so the runtime
needed to multiply an n by n matrix by a
vector and so when the input matrix is
bars fee of n equals o of n of two log
factors
now s omega corresponds to multiplying
two s by s matrices but s will denote
our blocking factor so we will introduce
blocks the input matrix is not blocked
um but we introduce them to improve the
runtime and so this will be the blocking
size
lastly enter the omega s denotes the
ransom needed to multiply two
rectangular matrices of size n by s and
syn
[Music]
okay so the setup follows the setup in
everlay at all and one remark is that
the runtime is expected because we need
to precondition the input matrix
and we need to precondition
the input matrix so that the
trial of matrices that i will now
describe are non-singular
but this is the only place in the
algorithm where randomization occurs and
everything else is deterministic
as i said we have a blocking size of s
and then m is defined as n divided by s
so then all matrices continue to have
size
and by n
and they have n blocks and then blocks
each of size s by s
okay so now we build a block vector u of
size n by s which constitutes of the
identity matrix of sas of size s by s i
s
placed
m times so that this has times uh this
has heis n by s
then using u we built the krylov
matrices ku and kv as described here kv
is almost a transpose of of ku but not
quite we will now see why it's defined
that way
um and they're called the krylov
matrices because they have uh this comes
from the krylov subspace so notice that
each
column corresponds to one of the
elements that span the pile of subspace
building this rule of matrices takes of
n times u of n operations
and a remark that this might look uh
rectangular but notice that k u and k v
are n by n matrices
well whereas this is a block vector
and a side note which i will not get
into but this is coming from green
descent because an m-step conjugate
gradient corresponds to finding the best
solution in the m-step krylov space
so so why do we need this kind of
matrices uh the key insight in our
little is that the gram matrix of the
curl of space matrix is a block henkel
matrix
what does this mean
so if we multiply kv times the input
matrix a times k u we get this matrix
which turns out to be very structured
so it's actually a block angle matrix
and an angle matrix a matrix where each
element along the transpose diagonal is
repeated so you see each element in this
transverse area unless repeated and the
same for each of them
and in this case we have repeated blocks
so it's a block angle matrix so it's
really structured
and building this long handle matrix
says only of n squared
but now if we take inverses
we see that we have decomposed the
inverse matrix into acrylic matrix an
inverse of a block angle matrix and
another carlos matrix
and so now the problem of inverting a
becomes the problem of inverting a block
handle matrix and so now we will turn to
determining how fast we can invert a
block angle matrix
let me now
present this problem with twelve blitz
matrices just because it's easier in the
notation side with transpose
uh so so a topology matrix is almost the
same as a angle except um now each
repeated element is along the diagonal
not the transposed diagonal
and so it's clear that the turbulence
matrix has a lot of structure but what
about the inverse of atomic blitz let's
do a small three by three example
well you see that unfortunately the
inverse of auto blades matrix is not
toilets but we could still hope that it
has some sort of structure
this is exactly the question that was
motivating the work by kyla
who introduced the notion of
displacement rank
which in a way tries to extract the
structure that exists in a toilet
inverse precisely because it is the
inverse of a very structured matrix
so now consider the circle and matrix z
which is defined as a matrix of all
zeros except this uh diagonal right
below the main diagonal which is all
ones
this matrix is interesting because when
we apply it to a matrix from the left it
shifts down a and we apply it from uh
the right transpose then it it moves the
matrix right so let's do an example with
toilets when we apply z you said we
shift it down and when we apply z
transpose we see that you shift it uh
right
so now if we if we subtract this matrix
from the original teleplates because of
the twelve lead structure we get a rank
two matrix because we get all zeros
except in the first row and in the first
column
and it's not rank two because the
initial matrix is size three by three
but this is true for any n by n matrix
okay but we
we kind of expect this from a tablet's
matrix but now if you consider the dual
operator and we say dual because we
switched c transpose and z which were z
and transpose the other time
and we apply the same operation to a toy
blitz inverse then we also get a rank
two matrix which was not at all obvious
um and that's also true for any n by n
matrix
so now we get to the displacement rank
theorem as stated by kyla's adult who
showed that the displacement rank of a
matrix is equal to the displacement rank
of the heating brace
and so we call
so this is called the displaced matrix
once we have applied this operator and
then the displacement rank is the rank
of the displacement matrix
and they say plus and minus because
we have to consider the dual operator so
that just means we have to switch the
two matrices um around
around a
so that means that proves that um
a toy blitz inverse has displacement
rank two because we saw that the
tablet's matrix has this position branch
too
but they also tell us how to relate the
displace matrix to the original matrix
because this displacement operator is in
vertical
so
this is a displaced matrix which has
rank alpha so we use alpha to denote the
displacement rank and because it has
rank alpha we can decompose it into
alpha products of two vectors x and y
are vectors so that's very succinct
they're just n by m times one
and now they tell us how to use these
vectors to build back the non-displaced
non-displaced matrix a
and and we do that by by placing these
vectors um x and y
into lower triangular uh matrices
let's see a visual example
this means we have a we apply the
displacement operator to the displaced
matrix which has rank alpha and so we
can express this display displaced
matrix with alpha generators of vectors
x and y
and now when i say we place it into this
lower triangular matrix this is how we
do it so we place the same entry
along each diagonal and then we build
these lu products
and then if we perform this these alpha
products we get back the non-displaced
matrix a
there's no inverse here that just just
the relationship between
a matrix and it's displaced version
well we already knew that fertilized
matrix that we could write it as two
earlier products because for a 12 matrix
alpha is equal to two but the key point
is the same theorem holds for the
inverse and so now we have reached the
conclusion that we can express a toy
blitz inverse
as two
value products
now we can also extend that to the block
case
in which
x and y instead of being vectors will
have size n times s so they are blocked
vectors and we will usually call them
the rectangular generators
notice that they give us a very sixteen
representation of the inverse the
inverse would normally take as m squared
times space to represent but now with
the rectangular generators we only need
space alpha ns
but now the question becomes okay that
gives us the relationship between a
matrix and its displaced version but we
care about the inverse so
so now we ask given a matrix a can we
find the rectangular generators of the
inverse quickly
and this was answered by bitmap and
anderson
in the 80s who showed how to find the
rectangular generators of the inverse in
time o tilde of s
to the omega times m
now the question is once we have these
rectangular generators what is the
fastest way to recover a inverse
explicitly so writing down the n squared
entries
and that's a question that we will now
try to answer but before two
generalizations
notice that um everything we're talking
about and everything i will now explain
it's not only for toi blitz matrices
it's all co4 toy blitz like matrices
meaning alpha doesn't have to be two it
can be anything that's asymptotically
small compared to n and the same results
hold because we can just ignore the
alpha factor
it also generalizes not only to toy
blitz and hoblits like matrices but to
other types of operators such as henkel
which is the one that we need cause she
wandermont and so on and many other
kinds of structure matrices
so what generally given the matrix we
define the the displacement operator of
a with respect to the structure matrix
so we would say displacement operator
with respect to the toilets operator for
example and then we have matrices p and
q
which in the case of toy blitz p was
equal to z and q to z transposed where z
was the circular matrix
um
and so for the hankel case it turns out
if you try it that uh you have that p
equals transpose q equals z and then you
also get a displaced matrix with rank
two
but you can also consider van der waals
she etc and we do in the paper
so the key takeaway is that displacement
operators yield compressed by linear
expressions for structure matrices
okay now let's go back to the angle
setting which is the one that we had um
a block chemical setting
and so with the bitlet and anderson
algorithm we find the rectangular
generators x y x star and y star
such that these holes and remember that
this is the l u um
expression given by the kailath at al
paper
now the question is how can we
recover h inverse explicitly in the
fastest way possible
so we want to build back
this matrix from this rectangular block
vectors
if we use convolutions and the fast free
transform we can actually do it quite
fast in time of s omega m squared but
another question is can we do this
better
now is when we will introduce
we will introduce fast rectangular
matrix multiplication to achieve a
better runtime
so now
what happens if we just multiply the
rectangular generators
um
we do not get the matrix that we want
right because we want this product we do
not want this product and so we put them
together you see that they're not
they're not the same matrix
however if we inspect them more closely
we see that we can establish
a recursion to obtain this matrix from
the matrix that's the rectangular
product of the generators
indeed you see that for example if we
look at this entry that's the sum of
these entries and that's true for any
uh any entry in this matrix which is
always the sum of the preceding values
in the diagonal
more generally that's true for any um n
by n matrix
and so that gives us a way
to build this matrix from this matrix
namely
we proceed in a dynamic programming
manner um and we go through the
diagonals of the of this matrix and we
add them out exclusively and then fill
in the entry of this matrix and then in
time only o of n squared we have
transformed this matrix into this
matrix but the key part is that we could
use fast rectangular matrix
multiplication to perform this product
which would we would not be able to use
here
so now we get one of the theorems in in
our paper which is that given a blocked
matrix a with disliking rank alpha with
respect to the total place and henkel
operator operator then we can compute
the explicit inverse in time of alpha
times n to the omega s
where remember that omega s corresponds
to the
exponent of rectangular matrix
multiplication of sizes
n times s and s times n
um then from the current work on
rectangular matrix multiplication so the
fastest
values of omega s by legal and ruthia we
get for any blocking factor s that's
smaller than n to the 0.31 then the
running time becomes essentially
quadratic which is the best that we can
hope for because just writing down the
inverse takes at least o of n squared
and by the way this is called the dual
exponent of matrix multiplication which
is defined as the largest number such
that the rectangular product still takes
um quadratic time
and as i said this theorem extends to
other types of displacement operators
such as van thermal matrices
okay so let's review the general scheme
we have a matrix a
then we use the bitmap anderson
algorithm to find the rectangular
generators of the inverse in time of s
omega
then we use
the algorithms for fast rectangular
matrix multiplication to multiply these
rectangular generators generators and
then we apply
the appropriate recursive formula for
set operator so the recursive formula
depends on whether the operator is toy
blitz angle or vendor mode but uh for
all of those we can always do it in time
o of n squared
and so the key strategy is that we want
to stay to work with the compressed
bilinear expressions for as long as
possible
[Music]
okay so now we know how to quickly
invert a block angle matrix so we can
return to the initial setting where we
need to invert an arbitrary unblocked
matrix a
so recall that we had this expression
for the inverse and now we have written
up h
inverse in time of alpha times n to the
omega s
and so to obtain the the inverse a we
only need to multiply by the trial of
matrices on each side and we can do this
quickly by using horner's scheme
um because if you remember the structure
of ku and kv we can successfully
multiply by a and so we can do this in
this time
so we finally obtain a inverse and so
the final runtime corresponds to this
expression that i showed in the
beginning
and now this term and this term
correspond to applying corner scheme and
also building the crowd of um the the
initial matrices the cryolog and the u
vector
this comes from using the bitmap and
anderson algorithm for finding the
rectangular generators and this comes
from using fast rectangular matrix
multiplication algorithms from legal and
rootia to multiply the rectangular
generators
now
if we optimize for block size because
remember that we introduced s and m to
improve the runtime but the original
matrix isn't blocked
then we obtain a final expected runtime
of o to the n o of n to the 221 31 for
sparse matrices which constitutes the
fastest known runtime for sparse matrix
inversion
moreover we find a very neat expression
for the runtime which is the runtime to
invert a matrix is o of n to the omega k
where k is the only value such that the
functions omega k and 3 minus k cross
where omega k corresponds to the
exponent
of rectangular matrix multiplication
with n times n to the k matrix times an
n to the k times n matrix
so you see that
the runtime for matrix inversion depends
only on the run time for rectangular
matrix multiplication meaning that any
improvement that is done for rectangular
matrix multiplication will immediately
improve the runtime for sparse matrix
conversion in which this value will just
go down this line
so let me finish with some final remarks
um as i said in the beginning the same
runtime holds for computing the rank and
true complement of sparse matrices more
generally if we have any algorithm that
inverts the matrix then we also have an
argument that computes the rank and no
space of the matrix by just adding the n
times v of n term
we can also extend our results to other
types of structure matrices as i
mentioned such as van der mart
we show some applications for concrete
examples and which we improve the
runtime for several algorithms in
topological data analysis and final
group theory which need
inverting matrices in the final field
setting
you can check out the extended work on
archive if you're interested
and as i mentioned also in the beginning
the main open question that remains is
that we still do not have any step
matrix multiplication algorithm for
sparse matrix inversion in the finite
position arithmetic setting which we do
know for sparse linear systems
so the main i will finish by giving the
the main takeaways of this talk and of
the paper
first is the interplay between finite
field algorithms and find precision
arithmetic algorithms as we saw there
are insights in both directions and
developing algorithms in either setting
provides
also grounds for finding algorithms in
the other setting
and
main the main point is that there are no
numerical errors in five fields and so
we don't need to worry about bit size
the second is that
it's a good idea always to decompose
arbitrary matrix into structure once
such as krylov and henkel and teleblades
and so on and when we have these
structural matrices displacement
operators turn out to be a very useful
tool when working with these structure
matrices
lastly fast rectangular matrix
multiplication can come to the rescue um
in many different algorithms such as
ours especially in this case when we
work with a compressed bilinear
expressions but it has turned out to be
another useful in other
theory computer science problems such as
the all-pers shortest path problems
with these the main takeaways i will
finish conclude the talk thank you very
much for your attention and
please feel free to reach out with any
questions if you have any